our body's immune system protects us
from all kind of harmful pathogens and
that's why we can compare our immune
system to the defense system of our
country which protects us at all cost
but sometimes things go wrong and in
order to prevent any kind of
autoreactive or self-destructive events
our immune system has tolerance
mechanism which is a safeguard mechanism
protecting our body from autoreactive
cells and autoimmunity but still things
can go wrong the cells can evade that
kind of mechanisms and there could be a
low to moderate consequence which might
lead to allergy rashes skin blemishes
etc it can also have chronic
consequences like autoimmune disorders
now hypersensitivity is a specific term
which is kind of explaining that the
immune system is overreacting let's say
we personified the immune system it's a
healthy person let's say now in response
to antigen when this immune system over
reacts this situation is now known as
hypersensitivity and it's quite
dangerous to the body right
few things we should question before
understanding hypersensitivity now when
the cells are autoreactive and when the
cells are oversensitive towards the
pathogens or antigens then that could
cause several danger signals to the body
now this trade that is supposed to the
body could has different timeline some
traits or consequence could be immediate
some could be delayed we should ask that
what are the mediators of
hypersensitivity at the level of cell or
molecules so let's just introduce all
the types of hypersensitivity that body
can face there is type 1
hypersensitivity which is also known as
allergy and it is mainly mediated by
allergens
and I GE and the Marcel's are the key
culprit of this pathway now Marcel's
bind to IgE because it has IgE receptor
and it can be granulate and produce many
many peptides like histamines which
would cause a lot of harmful
consequences on the body then type 2
hypersensitivity is basically IgG
mediated and this is also dependent upon
antibodies so it's an antibody mediated
type 2 hypersensitivity reaction it
leads to destruction of the cells by
complements if fixation or antibody
dependent cytotoxicity the type 3
hypersensitivity is due to immune
complexes where immune complexes deposit
in several places and leads to
hypersensitive response or inflammatory
response
so type 1 type 2 and type 3
hypersensitivity both I mean all of
these involves to some extent antigen
antibody interactions and all of these
has another thing in common which is
their occurrence is immediate so it's an
immediate consequence of the over
reactive or oversensitive immune system
there is another kind of
hypersensitivity which is type 4 also
known as delayed hypersensitivity
delayed hypersensitivity takes time to
occur and it involves specific
subpopulation of T helper cells econo
also known as th1 cells and unlike any
other hypersensitive response it
involves no antibody response knowing
antibody mediated responses and it only
involves T cells and in this video we'll
learn about all of these in a bird side
view but let's first try to understand
that how people figure out about this
hypersensitivity reaction what was the
first evidence
so it turns out that there are two
French scientist Paul Porter and Charles
Richard who found that the people who
are taking baths in Mediterranean Sea
are often getting bitten by jellyfish
now this jellyfish sting is pretty
painful right so they wanted to get a
cure of jellyfish pain and jellyfish
sting so what they used to do is isolate
the jellyfish toxin and that toxin is
then injected to a dog
now these toxin would possibly produce
antibodies if it's a proteinaceous toxin
it would produce antibodies against this
this particular toxin so they expected
when this dog is given a booster dose or
the second time then the dog would be
totally immune because it has all the
necessary antibodies to encounter that
toxin right but something came to as in
surprise instead of getting immune to
that situation the dog showed diarrhea
vomiting and eventually he died then
Charles which it called this
oversensitive and
over-reactive situation as anaphylaxis
and this was the first evidence of
hypersensitivity and now we know this
kind of situation is a delayed
hypersensitivity let's talk about first
about type 1 hypersensitivity reaction
so let's say this particular boy gives
this girl a rose along with this rose
there were pollen grains from other
flowers which this girl was allergic to
and the girl Dineen knew that so the
girl sniffs that rose and with that
beautiful smell of the rose allergens
enter her nasal cavity now inside the
nasal cavity under the respiratory
epithelium these allergens
get in and then that they are detected
by antigen presenting cells B cells etc
now the B cells which detect them and
eventually they would display their
antigens onto th T helper cells
activates these B cells and what would
happen is these B cells would
differentiate into plasma cells and the
plasma cells would secrete IgE an IgE is
the key mediator of type 1
hypersensitivity or
allergic reactions these IgE antibodies
can bind to the FC receptors present on
the mast cells and Prime these mast
cells now this might my cells become
sensitized and whenever there is a
second exposure the D granulate and the
degranulation of the mast cells has
consequences it can lead to smooth
muscle constriction vasodilation
bronchoconstriction and glandular
secretions and several consequences it
could have so this is all about type 1
hypersensitivity and few people are
always more prone to allergy because
they have more IgE and the antibodies
inherently and this kind of situation is
known as Autopia now this is not so
detailed information about type 1
hypersensitivity so if you want to know
more about it I have a separate video
and the link is at the end screen let's
talk about type 2 hypersensitivity for a
moment type 2 hypersensitivity is often
associated with blood transfusion or
mismatch transfusion we all know we have
4 type of blood groups blood group a B a
B and blood group O blood group a has a
antigen on its surface and in the serum
we have anti-b antibodies whereas in
case of blood group B we have an T 8th
antibody in the serum and antigen B in
the surface blood group a B has both the
antigens present on the surface but no
serum in the body no and
is in the serum now blood group O has an
T a and NTP both type of antibodies in
their serum but no antigens on the
surface now let's imagine that a person
with blood group a is donating blood to
a person who blood group B and total
disaster would happen so blood group a
has a antigen and blood group B has B
antigen and both has the reciprocal
antibodies for it so whenever the blood
group of the person who which has a like
blood group a it has the anti-b
antibodies right so now anti-b
antibodies would bind to this p antigen
and this B antigen is displayed on the
surface of the blood because it has a
blood transfusion from our person who is
b-positive
now two things could happen one is
complement mediated lysis of these RBC's
second since these antibodies if c
region is detected by macrophages and
many other cells which has their FC
receptor they could undergo antibody
dependent cellular cytotoxicity and
eventually it would lead to destruction
of the RBC same situation of type 2
hypersensitivity occurs during
erythroblastosis fetalis which is a
fetal humanizes problem in this
situation mother's body produce an t rh
antibody now these anti RH antibody can
move into the move through the placenta
get into the embryo and it can cause
hemolysis and eventually death of this
embryo so these are bad consequences of
type 2 hypersensitive reaction now in
order to understand type 3
hypersensitivity reaction we take a
simple example let's say a snake has
bitten you in the leg now the snake
talks in on the snake venom is now
inside your bloodstream you need a
treatment right and the treat
for this is an antiserum now this
antiserum
is generally generated inside a horse or
rabbit which is bitten by the same snake
earlier so it is expected that there
sinem would have the necessary antibody
against this snake venom right now when
you inject it these antibody goes inside
the bloodstream interacts with the snake
venom or snake toxin and kind of
neutralize it but one thing is different
because the antibody which we inject is
produced in the different species and it
is foreign to our body right so our body
would detect this as an antigen called
body would detectives as a foreign
substance so one body would produce
antibody against it and which would
eventually be detected by macrophages or
neutrophils which are having FC
receptors and that would try to create
that up but there are two when there is
too much production of these clumps or
too much production of these antigen
antibody complexes
it can also be deposited onto the blood
capillary or blood vessel wall now this
would bring about several changes
neutrophils could be attracted inside
the blood vessels and they could
degranulation and sometimes even damage
of the artery or the capillary wall
which could be detrimental and lead to
blood clotting in several reaching so
this was like type 3 hypersensitivity
reaction which mostly involves
complement fixation and like
antigen-antibody complex let's talk
about type 4 hypersensitivity which is a
delayed type hypersensitivity let's say
a person is exposed to poison oak or
poison ivy this poison ivy has a
compound or 'jewish all this or Esau
would go inside the skin and it would be
detected by the macrophages resident
macrophages there and these resident
macrophages would eventually activate T
cells and this T cells would
ultimately differentiate into th1 cells
which are inflammatory now when there is
a second exposure the response is like
amplified there are several T cells
which are activated faster and then they
would secrete all sort of inflammatory
cytokines and chemokines which would
attract more immune cells toward the
site of exposure and that would lead to
a elevated response and that leads to
the consequences of type 4
hypersensitive reaction so this video
was overall an overview of all the
hypersensitivity reaction in a nutshell
but if you want detailed explanation of
all of these I have the link at the end
of this video so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
big thumbs up don't forget to like share
and subscribe thank you